toute histoire et un début on va revenir
dans les années 80
g
je viens de d'enterrer ma maman
j'ai mon beau père qui est en prison
et j'ai été abandonné par mon père à
l'âge de deux ans
là je suis plaqué au sol
violemment j'ai les deux mains
menottées dans le dos
et une matraque sur la nuque et là je me
dis
ma vie commence mal
donc l'histoire les traits simples moi
je suis un enfant des quartiers
d'un milieu populaire
et avec une maman je vis avec ma mère
isolée et un beau-père qui fait des
allers retours entre la prison et la
maison
donc j'ai très peu d'appétence pour
l'école personne ne m'aide à la maison
arrive le collège il ya une salle de
boxe en bas de chez moi je m'y inscrire
et je passe plus de temps la salle de
boxe que au collège parce que je veux
devenir boxeur pour défendre ma maman
et à l'âge de 15 ans je quitte le
système scolaire
et là j'ai les deux pieds
dans la petite délinquance
a 17 ans quand ma maman décède j'ai les
portes de la grande délinquance qui
s'ouvre à moi avec un beau père braqueur
j'ai toutes les cartes de visite en main
donc le juge vont qui je passe et il va
me mettre
entre les mains d'un tuteur de la dass
parce que je suis orphelin en fait on
est ce tuteur de la drees
a la bonne idée de me faire faire du
théâtre
est là j'ai une vocation qui s'abat sur
moi
donc je me remets à lire je leur mets à
écrire à essayer d'écrire et puis
surtout essayer de parler parce qu'à
l'époque je ne parlais pas jacques
boilley
et puis je vais vouloir devenir comédien
professionnel
c'est mon obsession donc je vais même
passer des concours d'écoles nationales
la rue blanche l'esad école supérieure
d'art dramatique de la ville de paris et
puis pendant mes huit années de
formation de comédien je vais avoir un
mètre pendant trois ans entre autres
tous profs s'appelle jean laurent cochet
qui est décédé bien sûr qui va
m'apporter une pédagogie exigeante
et puis à l'âge de 29 ans avec ma
complice de toujours
florence forêt qui se reconnaîtra
nous créons un théâtre dans paris et
puis aujourd'hui à l'âge de 56 ans eh
bien je continue je suis metteur en
scène je suis comédien j'enseigne le
théâtre j'enseigne l'improvisation
j'enseigne l'art oratoire
et j'enseigne dans les universités l'art
de convaincre
la parole qui convainc la parole qui
sauvent et la parole qu'ils libèrent
alors pourquoi je vous raconte cette
histoire bain tout simplement parce que
bien sûr entre temps
pendant mes études de comédiens je
continuais la boxe j'avais des touches
avec l'insep bon mais c'est quelque
chose qui me plaisait énormément
et donc pourquoi je vous raconte cette
histoire parce que pour moi toute ma
pédagogie vient du théâtre et du sport
pour moi un comédien un sportif et un
orateur c'est le même combat les deux
les trois pardon vaut avoir plaisir
plaisir et envie et doivent avoir
plaisir et envie de communiquer
d'être là
se dépasser le comédien plaisir et envie
d'apprendre un texte pour un jouet sur
scène le sportif plaisir et envie le
plaisir dans le dépassement de soi
et l'orateur le plaisir de prendre la
parole de communiquer de partager et de
convaincre
parler
c'est s'impliquer
quand je m'implique
je m'engage
mais dans cette notion d'engagement
il doit y avoir aussi une part de
plaisir est en vie
je dis souvent à mes élèves l'enjeu ne
doit pas tuer le jeu j e
alors concernant le message puisque je
vais vous parler d'art oratoire
concernant le message la vocation
première d'un comédien qu'est ce qu'elle
est elle c'est de convaincre la vocation
première d'un orateur ça va être de
convaincre et les deux pour convaincre
devons avoir qu'une seule obsession
c'est d'incarner
leurs textes
incarner leur texte
louis jouvet que vous connaissez
certainement disait le texte appartient
à l'auteur
mais la pensée appartient à l'acteur
ça veut dire que là que l'orateur est là
et il apporte une plus-value
devant un public un texte écrit et fait
pour être lu un romancier quand il écrit
son texte simplement pour être pour être
lu dans notre intimité mais un texte dit
est fait pour être entendu ces deux
métiers deux méthodes et deux stratégies
complètement différente
on m'a souvent dit celui qui a des idées
mais qui ne s'est pas à les exprimer
n'est pas plus avancé que celui qu'il en
a pas
un mois donc vous qui m'écoutent et si
vous avez des idées et que vous doutez
vous ne savez pas trop comment les
exprimer je vais vous dire une chose je
vais vous offrir un secret je vous
offrez un cadeau d'ailleurs et c'est
très simple
il vous suffit de savoir compter jusqu'à
1 2 3
ce sont ces le secret des orateurs
parce que lorsque vous êtes ici vous
devez être vu entendu compris le corps
la voix les mots clairs dans l'émission
du discours concis dans la syntaxe et
court dans la durée vous devez aussi
connaître cette fameuse règle des 3 x 20
les vingt premières secondes 20 premiers
gestes 20 premiers mots
vous devez jouer avec les trois
registres du langage l'effet opinion
sentiments ce que je constate ce que je
pense et ce que je ressens
vous devez enfin structurer votre
message en trois parties introduction
développement conclusion
convaincre en trois minutes un pour ceux
qui connaissent ma thèse en 180 secondes
c'est amplement suffisant et bien sûr
connaître le triptyque grecque ethos
logos pathos formalisé par cicéron
aristote et platon voilà un deux trois
c'est le secret de l'orateur
alors moi je vais vous parler de trois
outils très simples pour gagner en
impact
alors vous allez voir pas besoin d'aller
chercher à droite à gauche c'est très
simple
les ressources sont en nous
dantec et voilà il faut aussi
s'entraîner je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure par rapport au sport l'art
oratoire c'est une c'est une épreuve
sportive il ya bien sûr la préparation
mais il ya l'entraînement très important
et puis l'action et d'ailleurs je suis
pas le seul à le dire il ya un monsieur
qui s'appelle bertrand perrier que vous
devez certainement connaître qui a écrit
un bouquin génial qui s'appelle la
parole est un sport de combat je suis
pas le seul 1
alors tout d'abord le corps voilà trois
outils le corps la voix et les mots le
corps
sachez que le corse et 70% de ce qu'on
va retenir de vous
au temps bien maîtrisée donc le corps
anton tchekhov disait notre corps peut
être notre meilleur ami comme notre pire
ennemi
on a plusieurs énergies dans le corps on
peut être nous on peut être normal
tonique excité explosif voilà donc quand
je suis un orateur quand je suis là face
à un public même devant 4 5 personnes
moi je préconise d' être tonique
ensuite dans le corps vous avez un
muscle le muscle le plus long du corps
humain que vous devez tous connaître et
qui s'appelle le diaphragme et ce
diaphragme là va nous permettre son jeu
la soupe libyen d'avoir une respiration
abdominale et cette respiration
abdominale va me permettre d'avoir un
corps souple
des idées claires va me permettre de
bien gérer mes émotions
et puis d'avoir du volume dans la voix
et ensuite il ya les gestes alors ça le
nombre de personnes qui me dit je ne
sais pas quoi faire mes mains bon voilà
leslie au bout de tes bras ça c'est la
vanne
une fois qu'on a dit ça finalement on
n'a rien dit en fait le problème c'est
l'incarnation du message tout à l'heure
je vous en parlais c'est la pensée du
message c'est quand vous êtes avec des
amis
et que vous racontez vos vacances
on pensait pas votre gestuelle ouais on
est allé en espagne on à manger des
tapas on a bu des bières on a dance etc
voilà y'a aucun souci quand vous êtes à
la boulangerie vous n'êtes pas en train
de dire la branche charbon jours jours
d'un proche au cola chausson aux pommes
j'sais pas quoi faire de mes bras je
suis désormais dit de les bouger donc
non pourquoi parce que votre gestuelle
elle va suivre votre pensée
et en tant qu'orateur si vous ne vous
êtes pas bien préparé et bien forcément
la gestuelle elle va être empêtrés
d'où la nécessité de l'entraînement
ensuite il y à l'ancrage voilà l'ancrage
c'est être stable jean de la fontaine a
écrit une fable qui s'appelle le chêne
et le roseau
le roseau plie mais ne rompt pas
et bien moi je propose toujours aux
orateurs de plier mes parents d'être
stable dans l'instable instable c'est
quoi c'est la situation que nous vivons
quand je suis face un public c'est pas
très stable on a le trac on se demande
si on va pas avoir des trous de mémoire
on sait pas trop comment est-ce qu'on
est donc c'est pas stable même devant
400 personnes 1 donc la préparation
l'entraînement va me permettre de
trouver une stabilité dans le sport on
appelle ça la pensée réflexive
aujourd'hui je cours des marathons bon
là quand je cours je suis en capacité de
savoir exactement kilomètre par
kilomètre
ou est-ce que j'en suis sur mon chrono
c'est à dire que je suis dans l'instant
présent
l'ici et maintenant
ensuite vous avez la voix la voix c'est
20% de ce qu'on va retenir de vous donc
la voie voilà c'est important la voix
on a une tessiture compris entre 2
octaves huit notes et puis il ya
l'articulation les intonations les
intentions la modulation le rythme les
silences pas c'est énorme
arrêtons nous un tout petit peu sur
l'articulation
voilà moi je dis toujours qu'un orateur
qui n'articule pas
ça ne m'intéresse pas je ne les écoute
pas
l'articulation c'est la politesse de
l'orateur
vous faisait des petits exercices comme
ça il ya plein plein de petits exercices
d'ailleurs vous vous entraînerez c'est
dire je vais chez ce cher c'est
rechercher ses chaussettes sèchent ou
alors papier panier piano papier panier
piano papier panier piano vous
entraînera
ensuite il ya les intonations et les
intentions victor hugo disait la forme
c'est le fond qui remonte à la surface
regarder une intention par exemple tout
simple je dis à ma femme qui est un
shérif ce soir est ce que tu vas on va
au théâtre mais je peux lui dire bon
chérie tu viens ont voté un ce soir
chéri tu viens beau théâtre ce soir
voilà c'est 3 intentions différentes
et là elle peut me répondre mais c'est
bon on m'agresse pas quoi je t'adresse
pas si tu m'agresses
et je m'en suis pas rendu compte
derrière cette phrase là je vais coloré
ma phrase d'une certaine manière fait
peut-être le fond voilà et puis enfin
moi ce que je vous propose si vous avez
des petits enfants ou des enfants balisé
l'heure des histoires parce que il n'ya
rien de mieux que de lire des histoires
aux enfants pour qu'ils puissent propos
pour que vous pour que vous vous
habituez avec votre appareil phonatoire
lire des histoires intentions modulation
vous mettez du rythme vous mettez vous
articulé si l'enfant de 4 ans se met à
courir partout posez vous des questions
mais si jamais il est attentif alors là
vous dites waouh je suis le meilleur
orateur du monde ce qu'un enfant de 4
ans ça triche pas un général et puis
ensuite bien sûr il ya les silences
alors ici on est obligé parce que ça
résonne mais les silences important ça
va appuyer ce que vous avez dit ou alors
confirmé ce que vous allez dire le
silence à n'est pas un blanc ça n'est
pas un trou
on pose des silences pour permettre à
l'auditoire
de recevoir le message que je suis en
train de dire
et ensuite les mots alors les mots notez
bien ces 5% entre 5 et 10% de ce qu'on
retient voilà le corps 70 là la voix 20%
et les mots soit 5 5 à 10%
nicolas boileau disait ce qui se conçoit
bien s'énonce clairement et les mots
pour le dire arrivent aisément
paul valéry dit les mots bien utilisés
sont comme des rayons laser
et moi je dis un objectif flou se
traduit toujours par une connerie
précise
donc
moi j'ai toujours fait vu mon parcours
je vous expliquais tout à l'heure j'ai
toujours fait confiance aux aînés voilà
c'est grâce à eux si j'en suis là
aujourd'hui
et il ya un aîné il ya un
pas comme on pourrait dire mais qui
qui s'appelle quintilien
bon je n'ai pas connu un voilà mais
qu'était pédagogue latin 1er siècle
après jésus-christ voilà et qui lui nous
disait mais posez vous les bonnes
questions
voilà quand vous préparez votre discours
posez vous les bonnes questions qui dit
quoi à qui où quand comment et pourquoi
qui je suis le coeur du message qu'est
ce que je vais dire acquis qu'elle est
publique qui je m'adresse ou pas le lieu
quand à quel moment de la journée
commencer ma stratus stratégies
argumentatives et d'ailleurs ça
utiliser le storytelling c'est important
il ya un monsieur qui s'appelle anthony
rivière je vous conseille il a écrit un
livre fabuleux aussi qui s'appelle
l'homme est un conteur d'histoires nous
aimons tous entendre des histoires
combien de personnes ne disaient dès que
tu nous raconte une anecdote c'est sympa
dès que tu nous racontes des histoires
c'est sympa voilà un souvent c'est pour
ça que les profs d'histoire-géo
généralement ont beaucoup de succès en
cours parce que tiens je vais vous
raconter une histoire à tout à coup les
élèves hop ils élèvent leurs oreilles
dit ah ouais enfin quelque chose
d'intéressant
et ensuite pourquoi dans quel but vous
parlez si vous parlez pour convaincre si
vous parlez pour pour motiver ou si vous
parlez pour informer enfin bref il ya
plusieurs buts
quand on prend la parole
et puis enfin la structuration du
message tout à l'heure je lui ai dit 1 2
c'est le secret des orateurs ben voila
moi j'aime bien je suis très pragmatique
je sais pas si c'est le sport qui me l'a
apporté ou pas mais ce pragmatisme à
l'anglo saxonne les anglais et dix
comme le message de toute façon les gens
n'en entende qu'une petite partie n'en
répète qu'une petite partie c'est pas la
peine de faire des longs discours
trois minutes suffit là aujourd'hui je
suis obligé de faire de 15000 mais trois
minutes suffisent
introduction développement conclusions
dis moi ce que tu vas me dire dis le moi
il répète moi ce que tu viens juste de
me dire les anglais disent tell me what
you want to tell me tell me et tell me
what you just to told me
la redondance
voilà donc
merci beaucoup de m'avoir écouté un deux
trois c'est le secret des orateurs le
corps la voix les mots au service du
discours
[Applaudissements]